and some human society is as similar in
many ways they live in communities
numbering from just a few individuals up
to many millions they can build vast
empires that span the world they conduct
diplomacy with neighboring settlements
and they can even go to war with each
other
all the ants have just one single intent
on their mind and that's the
reproductive success of the colony
everything that they do is directed
towards that one aim most an colonies
consist of just one reproductive
individual the queen and many non
reproductive workers and the workers are
actually all female so they're a vast
sisterhood who does all the work now the
title Queen seems to imply some kind of
political authority that the queen is
telling the workers what to do at any
one moment in time but in fact is
completely self organized in a colony of
ants there are no fixed managers there
are no CEOs or presidents everyone is
working towards the common goal
if one ant finds a trace of food that ad
will become in that moment a leader and
get everyone else to come into that food
source but the modern organization is
obsessed with hierarchy obsessed with
managers and where you are up on the
scale which number or Pedro you are and
what happens is lots of people lower
down spend all their time trying to
guess what their manager wants or their
managers managers want rather than
what's going to work for the
organization and the people they serve
when an ant encounters a food source for
example what it can do on the way back
to the colony is lay a trail using
pheromones and these are just chemicals
that they can lay on the ground so that
when other ants come along and encounter
that trail they know to follow it all
the way to the food so this simple
process of positive feedback is
surprisingly effective at finding the
shortest path the idea borrowing from
the underworld of actually getting the
data making sure you're capturing it
from the very people who are on the
coalface so to speak makes tons of sense
because they're the ones with the rich
qualitative data to be able to feed that
back into the decision-making there to
be self organized we have to allow
people to have their own intelligence
and wisdom and organize around a problem
or a project themselves while they're
always waiting for someone else to tell
them what to do or for a three-year
business planning cycle to take effect
just as ants respond immediately to
changes in their environment say the
diminishing of a foraging patch and
adapt really quickly to that change
organizations must be able to do the
same if look by looking at ants for
instance it stimulates our thinking
about how we might try to do things
differently then that's worth it in and
of itself I just think you'd probably
want to start experimenting in a quite
small and bounded way but yeah why not
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon